more worrisome are the side effects that
the sharp palsy tightening of the last
12 months is starting to have on the
financial sector
we have repeatedly warned this would not
be an easy ride
following a prolonged period of muted
inflation and low interest rates the
financial sector had become too
complacent towards maturity and
liquidity mismatches last year's rapid
policy tightening triggered sizable
losses on long-term fixed income assets
and increased Bank funding costs
the brief instability last fall in the
United Kingdom's guilt market and the
recent banking turbulence in the United
States illustrate instead that
significant vulnerabilities do exist
both among Banks and non-bank financial
institutions in both cases financial and
monetary authorities to quick and strong
action and so far have prevented further
instability broader markets have
remained calm and volatility has been
contained including for emerging and
developing economies
increasing funding costs and the need to
act more prudently however may push
Banks to cut down lending further in a
world economic Outlook we explore such a
scenario and find that it would lead to
an additional 0.3 reduction in output
this year
yet the financial system May well be
tested even more nervous investors often
look for the next weakest link as they
did with Credit Suisse globally systemic
but ailing European Bank financial
institutions with excess leverage credit
risk or interest rate exposure too much
dependence on short-term funding or
located in jurisdictions with limited
fiscal space could become the next
Target so could countries with weaker
perceived fundamentals a sharp
tightening of Global Financial
conditions will sometimes call the
risk-off event would have a dramatic
impact on credit conditions and public
finances especially in emerging market
and developing economies
it would precipitate large capital
outflows a sudden increase in risk
premium a dollar appreciation in a rush
towards safety and major declines in
global activity amid lower confidence
in such a severe downside scenario
Global growth this year could fall to
about one percent an outcome was
probability we estimate at about 15
percent
will therefore entering a tricky phase
during which economy growth remains Low
by historical standards Financial risks
have increased yet inflation has not
decisively decisively turned the corner